اهلا بكم مشاهدي الكرام احييكم انا ماجد
حميد الى هذا الحوار الخاص مع دوله رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد الشاع السوداني
للحديث عن عدد من الملفات منها الداخليه
والخارجيه مرحبا دوله الرئيس شكرا لك على
هذا الحوار ابدا من الملف الضاغط بعد
استلام الحكومه وعبور مئه يوم هو ملف
الدولار جنابك كنت قد تحدثت وقلت بانه على
العراقيين اقتناء الدينار العراقي بدل
الدولار لان الدينار ما زال قويا ومن ثم
ذهب وفد الى واشنطن وتراجع الدولار امام
الدينار لكن ما زال هناك تذبذب دوله
الرئيس هل هناك شروط فرضت من واشنطن على
العراق في موضوع
الدولار هل تمكنتم من وقف عمليه تهريب
الدولار الى خارج العراق بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم تحيه لكم ولمشاهدي قناتكم الكريمه
الدولار
وتذبتوبات الاسعار هي تتعلق بقضيه عانه
منها
سياسه عانت منها السياسه الماليه النقديه
منذ فتره بما يسمى نافذه بيع العمله
والحديث واللفظ الذي رافق هذا الملف طين
السنوات وجنابك شاهد عليها
وكل ما نريد ان نوجد حل مع المؤسسات
الماليه كان هناك نوع من الترحيل هذا
الملف منذ عام 2015
الى ان حصل اتفاق بين الخزانه والفتران
الامريكي مع البنك المركزي في الحكومه
السابقه
على الالتزام
بيسموها معايير الامتثال للنظام المصرفي
العالمي
وانتوا هذه المعايير
والالتزام بهذا النظام مده سنتين
حتى تتاقلم المصارف الاهليه ونظام
التحويلات والتعامل مع المنصه الالكترونيه
للاسف لم تكن الاجراءات المتخذه من قبل
الحكومه السابقه وخصوصا المركزي بالمستوى
الذي يؤهل هذا هذه المؤسسات الماليه
العراقيه للتعامل مع هذا التغيير فكانت
البدايه او انتهاء المده مع بدايه عمل
الحكومه
فاكتشفنا انه مصارفنا تجارنا ما يعرفون
المنصه متعودين على نظام من التحويلات
صارت هذه العمليه عالجناها بشتى القرارات
والاجراءات
ومنها تخفيض سعر الصرف اللي هو اساسا كان
امر مطروح لانه تعرف قرار رفع سعر الصرف
في حينها في 21 ما كان قرار مدروس واثر
بشكل واضح على الطبقات الفقيره ومحدوديه
الدخل والطبقه المتوسطه في المجتمع وساهم
في رفع نسبه التضخم وجاء في وقتها بحجه
انه الوضع المالي كان صعب الان الوضع
المالي العراقي في افضل حالات
ومن اقول الدينار قوي
ولن نسمح بانهيار الدينار
هذه الثقه تاتي من ان هناك وضع اقتصادي هو
الافضل في تاريخ العراق من حيث
الايرادات ومن حيث الرصيد الكلي للعمله
اللي تجاوز 100 مليار دولار لكن دوله
الرئيس القرار الصرف الذي اتخذ في مجلس
الوزراء مؤخرا الى 1300 نعم لماذا لماذا
لم يطبق هل هو يعني ينتظر اقرار الموازنه
لكي يطبق لا لا تم تنفيذه خلال 48 ساعه
التنفيذه في البنوك الحكومه الان اي تاجر
اي مواطن وفق المنافذ الرسميه يتعامل مع
1320 وهذا متاح المشكله انه بعض التجار
والشركات وخصوصا صغار التجار متعودين على
التحويلات لان هذا لا عنده اجازه استيراد
اصلا ما مسجل
متاقلم يدفع ضريبه وقمرك يخابر شركه
الصيرفه وشركه الصيره فتحول للمبلغ
لاحدى العواصم ويجيب البضاعه مالته لكن
نتحدث بصراحه دوله الرئيس وشرط كان لديها
مشكله في التهريب الدولار الى ايران تركيا
سوريا لبنان من كان يقف خلف عمليه التهريب
وهل العراق يمتلك نظاما مصرفيا الاهليه
الصحيح البعض يرى في البنوك والمصارات
الاهليه هي انشئت فقط للاستفاده من مزاد
العمله كما اشار تقرير النزاهه بانه اكثر
من
يعني مبالغ ضخمه جدا
هربت بسبب هذا المزاد موضوع التهريب
المضاربه بالدولار السعر الموازي هذا كلها
موجوده في كل دول العالم
وهناك لا نخفي هناك دول وتجار يستفيدون من
هذه العمليه وكانت احد الاشكالات المهمه
المطروحه على نافذه بيع العمله وعلى اداء
المصارف الاهليه اللي تشكلت بسرعه كبيره
بحيث وصلت عده 78 مصرف
ما محتاجين 78 بصراحه
وسبعين مصرف سبع مئه شركه صرافه كل شغلها
هو نافذه بيع العمله والتحويلات في حين
احنا نعرف اليوم المصارف الاهليه
يفترض الها دور في التنميه تساهم في عمليه
التمويل واقراض المستثمرين ورجال الاعمال
لتاسيس مشاريع اقعد مع المصارف الاهليه
اغلبها يعني حتى لا نظلم البعض من عده
اللي قاعد يعمل بشكل صحيح
وقعد تساعده احنا كحكومه لانه ماكو تنميه
بدون مصارف بدون نظام مصرفي فاكو اشكال
على اداء بعض المصارف الاهليه النسبه
الكبيره من عندهم فعمليه التهريب موجوده
تستفاد منها دول المنطقه وهذا جزء من
الاجراءات والقرارات المهمه اللي اتخذناها
ولحد الان حكومه اقليم كردستان تبدي دعم
الاكثر من ذلك في السيطره على منافذ التي
تهرب هذا الدولار
الى خارج العراق هذا جزء مهم واحد من اهم
الاجراءات اللي تسيطر على اسعار الصرف
بشكل متواصل الاتفاق مع الجانب الامريكي
هل هو الطويل الامد ام لا اعطوكم ايضا مده
جديده لمراقبه موضوع الدولار
احنا ماكو اشتراطات
ولا من غيرها ولا نقبله الاشتراطات بالعكس
كان الحوار حوار مهني اقتصادي صرف
واتحدثنا معاهم
بهذه المعايير واحنا نريد نلتزم فيها لانه
احنا نريد التجاره
واضحه تجاره وتحويلات ضمن المعايير
الدوليه للنظام المالي المصرفي لكن كان
هناك حوار بشان المرونه في بعض الاجراءات
التفاهم على بعض القرارات ضمن هذا الاطار
وكانت وجهات النظر متطابقه بين الطرف نعم
جنابك ابن العماره
من الجنوب العراقي هل يرضيك حال الفرات
ودجله يعني في زياره للامين العام للامم
المتحده كان يتحدث بصراحه عن ماء المخاوف
لمستقبل العراق ومستقبل المياه هناك من
يقول دوله الرئيس وانا يعني لا تتحملها
هذه الحكومه هو الموضوع منذ سنوات هل
العراق قادر على اخذ حصص الحصص المياه من
ايران وتركيا ام لا الموضوع صعب
موضوع شحه المياه وانخفاض مناسيب نهريه
دجله والفرات نتيجه عده ظروف
منها وهذه اسبابها واضحه يعني ما حد
ينكرها
شحت الامطار
تعرضنا الى موسم الجفاف في اكثر من مره
يمكن هذه السنه الله سبحانه وتعالى انعم
علينا في بعض الايام المنظره هذا سبب
رئيسي ليس فقط في العراق وانما في كل دول
المنطقه هذا واحد اثنين
دول الجوار للاسف لجات الى سياسات مائيه
خلاف الاتفاقات او خلاف المعايير اللي
تحكم الدول المتشاطئه في مساله اطلاق
وتوزيع الحصص المائيه وهذا خاضع لحوار
ولجان مستمره لغايه اليوم عندنا وفد مع
رجال تركيا وهناك استئناف في اللجنه
العراقيه الايرانيه بشان الانهر المشترك
هذا جهد نبدا له والشيء الثالث اللي نعترف
فيه هو ان هناك تخلف في اداره المياه داخل
العراق من حيث اعتماد الاساليب التقليديه
في السقي بالنسبه للمزارعين لحد الان انت
اركب لك طياره هليكوبتر وخذ لك جوله على
اطراف بغداد شوف البحيرات الاسماك
هذه المسطحات المائيه الواسعه هذا الشيء
ما موجود اليوم في كل دول المنطقه اليوم
نتحدث عن شحه حقيقيه في في المياه نعمل
على كل الاصعده والاتجاهات ونحاول ان نؤمن
لرؤيه الفطام بالنسبه للمزارعين وان نحافظ
على استمراريه عمل محطات المياه
مكافحه الفساد الشعار من كل الحكومات
العراقيه والعراقيين يتحدثون بان الحكومه
تبدا في مكافحه الفساد ومن ثم تتوقف ما هو
الخط الاحمر الذي سيتوقف لديه السيد محمد
الشيعه السوداني في مكافحه الفساد بصراحه
لا توجد خطوط حمراء في مجال مكافحه الفساد
ابدا وانا منذ اليوم الاول في جلسه
التكليف اطلقت مصطلح جائحه الفساد وانا
اعني هذا المصطلح لان الفساد هو التحدي
رقم واحد الان للدوله العراقيه مو داعش
الفساد
الفساد هو الذي يعطل التنميه هو الذي يؤخر
العمار هو الذي يساهم في هدر الاموال التي
تاتي من ايراداتنا في هذه الفتره ايرادات
النفطيه اللي يفترض ان تستغل بالشكل
الصحيح والمدروس
للفساد فقط السرقه بالمناسبه الفساد ان
تستخدم الاموال في قرارات مو صحيحه الان
عندك ايرادات
ماليه يفترض توجهها للمكان الصحيح اللي
يفعل قطاعات مهمه لتحريك الاقتصاد الوطني
هذا هو الذي نعمل ونتحرك عليه الفساد
مسؤوليه تضامنيه مطلوب من الجميع من
المواطن للمؤسسات من اصغر موظف الى اعلى
مسؤول في الدوله العراقيه
ايضا
كلنا امل في الدول الشقيقه والصديقه
والعالم كله اللي يتعاون مع العراق في
مساله استرداد الاموال والمطلوبين لانه
اغلب الفاسدين للاسف ذهبوا الى دول واخذوا
جنسيات للحمايه ونقلوا اموالهم يعني
هاي دائما انا اقولها للطرفه اقول هنا حتى
بالفاسدين هم ما محظوظين هسه اكو فاسدين
يخلي فلوسه بالعراق وتشتغل لا هذا حتى
فلوسه ياخذها بره فاذا المطلوب من هذه
الدول ان تتعاون مع العراق في تسليم
المطلوبين والاموال واحنا جزء من
الاتفاقيه الدوليه
لمكافحه الفساد نعم ممكن دوله الرئيس ان
يكون هناك اكتشاف لسرقات موازيه لسرقه
القرن اللي قام بها نور زهير
خطوره
سرقه الضمانات
الضريبيه من وجهه نظري ان هناك نوع او فئه
من الموظفين من المسؤولين محميه من بعض
الجهات السياسيه
عندها قرار انه تتجاوز على المال العام
بذاك الحجم الذي حصل مع ضمانات الضريبيه
وهذا الاخطر هذا منين اجى الشعور لهذه
الفئه لهؤلاء السراق من ضعف الاجراءات في
محاسبه والردع المطلوب لانه لو كان هناك
ردع حقيقي ما يتجرا لا هذا المتهم ولا
غيره في التجاوز على المال الان متى ما
كان هناك ردع ومحاسبه وفق القانون وبشكل
مهني بدون استثناء
انتقائيه في حينها ما اتوقع تكون هناك اي
سرقه لا سرقه قرن ولا سرقه انتقل الى
الملف السياسي دوله الرئيس كيف تنظر لوجود
حكومه عراقيه منذ عام 2003 بدون التيار
الصدري هل هناك تواصل مع التيار الصدري هل
تم مناقشه او كتل سياسيه تطرح ان تكون
هناك وساطه مع التيار الصدري هل تحدثت مع
السيد مقتدى الصدر مؤخرا او احد من التيار
طبعا قرار التيار الصدري بالانسحاب من
البرلمان
قرار مؤسف نحتربه هذا القرار لكنه
بالتاكيد لا يمكن تجاهل وجود تيار سياسي
مهم ومؤثر وفاعل في العمليه السياسيه منذ
تاسيسها
كان موجود بالعمليه السياسيه وكان موجود
في كل الحكومات والدورات البرلمانيه
فوجوده مهم
نختلف نتفق في بعض المواقف لكن هذه طبيعه
العمليه السياسيه في نظام نيابي متنوع
هذه الحكومه حريصه على مد الجسور مع
الجميع لا توجد لدينا محددات في التفاهم
في التعاطي في التشاور حتى مع الناس اللي
خارج
البرلمان او الحكومه انا حريص على مد جسور
التفاهم التشاور الحوار الاست ماع الى
النقد المهني البناء
وهذه السياسه متبعه من قبلنا كحكومه وانا
لمست حتى موجوده في ائتلاف اداره الدوله
من كافه القوه السياسيه لكل حريص على
الوجودات
للتيار الصدري من مسؤولين في مختلف مواقع
الدوله نتعامل معاهم وفق السياقات الرسميه
لكن لم يجد اي اتصال مع السيد مقتدى الصدر
ممكن يتوجه لرساله
معنا هذه رسالتي سماحه السيد مقتدى الصدر
شخصيه مهمه في الوسط السياسي والتيار
الصدري الفاعل نامل وجوده ومشاركته في كل
الفعاليات السياسيهم في خدمه البلد والشعب
كنت شديد في الاجتماع الاخير لمجلس
الوزراء مع الوزراء طلبت من عندهم
الابتعاد عن السياسه وانهم الان عند جلوس
في هذا المنصب يمثلون الدوله يمثلون تقديم
خدمات للمواطنين لكن هناك من يقول بان
رئيس الوزراء يلتزم اسبوعيا بالجلوس في
اجتماع مع الاطار التنسيقي وفي اجتماع مع
ائتلاف الدوله هناك من يرى بان
الطبخ الحكومي القرارات الحكوميه تتخذ في
هذه الاجتماعات هل هذا صحيح ام لا
مطبخ السياسي هو مجلس الوزراء ولا توجد
غرفه اخرى لاتخاذ القرار الذي يتعلق
بالدوله ونقطه راستر هذا واحد اثنين حرص
الحكومه بشخص رئيس الحكومه في التواصل في
الاجتماعات السياسيه سواء كان مع الاطار
او مع ائتلاف اداره الدوله كل اسبوعين هذا
من اجل بناء ثقه بين الحكومه والبرلمان
طبعا بوجود رئيس البرلمان مع القوه
السياسيه مشكله العمليه السياسيه ان هناك
ضعف ثقه بين القوى السياسيه تؤثر على اداء
الحكومه والبرلمان
اثنين احنا عندنا اتفاق سياسي والاتفاق
السياسي في الديباجه الالتزام ما يتم
الاتفاق عليه لا يجب ان لا يتعرض مع
الدستور والقانون الدستور والقانون يقول
الصلاحيات التنفيذيه لرئيس الوزراء
واضح ورئيس الوزراء وحكومته الوزير يتم
ترشيحه وانا اللي اصريت الوزراء يتم
ترشيحهم من القوى السياسيه وانا اختار وفق
معايير انا ثبتتها انطيتهم المعايير واحد
اثنين ثلاثه واختارهم
من اؤكد على قضيه انه الوزير تنتهي علاقته
بمجرد الاتفاق عليه موافقتي عليه
موافقتي اعتباطن يعني خابرته بالتليفون
قلت له فلان انت صرت وزير لا اجيت وقعدت
قلت لي رشحتك الكتله الفلانيه تنتهي
علاقتك تشتغل وفق البرنامج وهكذا بعد
مساله انه هيمنه هذا الحزب السياسي او ذاك
على الوزير او التحكم بسياسه الوزاره هذا
امر مرفوض
المغلقه وكل القوه السياسيه حريصه على هذا
الامر متفقين احنا عليه فانا لبست بعض
الوزارات انه فيها
للاسف تجاوز او تنصل عن هذا الاتفاق تنبهت
هالمره نبهت بشكل عام المره الثانيه لا
راح اشخص بالاسم وممكن تذهب الى تغيير
وزاري نعم بالتاكيد التغيير الوزاري ممكن
وفق مؤشرات مهنيه عندي تقييم انا عندي
لجان الان تعمل ليل نهار تتابع بادق
التفاصيل عندي برنامج حكومي عندي مؤشرات
اخرى عندي تقارير من هيئه النزاهه من
ديوان الرقابه الماليه من تقييم النواب
وعلى هذا الاساس اقول هذا الوزيري يصلح
يبقى انه نعطيه فرصه او لا يصلح اروح
للبرلمان وغيره نعم ملف الحدود دوله
الرئيس اتخذتم قرار بانفتاح قطاعات الحدود
باتجاه اقليم كردستان لمنع الهجمات
الايرانيه والتركيه باتجاه اقليم كردستان
هل استكملتم عمليه ضبط الحدود مع تركيا
تركيا ما صارت تقصف في سنجار هل استكملتم
عمليه ضبط الحدود وهل ممكن للعراق ان
يدافع عن سيادته بشكل اكبر والحفاظ على
هذه السياده اي ارتداء على الحدود مرفوض
من اي دوله
وبعد الاعتداءات التي حصلت من
الجاره ايران وتركيا رفضنا بمواقف رسميه
ومعلنه فيها اجراءات استدعاء سفراء من هذه
السياقات لكن هذا الامر لا ينتهي بهذه
المواقف يحتاج الى بحث وحوار اولا احنا
عندنا دستور الزم الحكومه بعدم السماح لاي
جهه ان تستخدم الارضيه منطلق للاعتداء على
دول الجوار عندنا اشكاليه انت من تتواجد
عندك معارضه
لاي دوله او لاجئين شو تريد تسميهم بموجب
القوانين العراقيه
فيفترض ان تحترم وجودها وجودها المدني
السلمي مو تاسس وتشكل وتنشئ معسكرات
وتدريب وتستخدم هذه الحدود
للدخول في ايران او تركيا وتقوم باعمال
مسلحه وترجع للارض العراقيه وهذا امر مو
صحيح العراق ما يقبله احنا ما نريد نهدد
امن دول الجوار كل دول للمنطقه لا يمكن ان
نقبل انه الاراضي العراقيه تستخدم منطلق
للاعتداء على اي دوله هذا التزام دستوري
وهل من الممكن ان تفرض عدوى لا ايضا تهاجم
الاراضي العراقيه حين اتخاذ الحكم العراقي
هي اجراءاتها مع هذا الامر مرفوض تماما
يعني هذا مو مبرر للدوله الجاره ان تقوم
بنفسها
عمليه استهداف لهذه الطرف ابدا مو صحيح
هذا اقول انه يجب ان نؤدي واجبنا وهذا ما
المطلوب وهذا ياتي بصيغه الحوار وبالفعل
هذا الحوار انتج استقرار وعدم اعتداء
وحاليا لجان مشتركه بين الطرفين والشيء
المهم انه بدانا بالتعاون مع الاخوه في
حكومه اقليم كردستان وفق الدستور بمسك
الحدود الرسميه بقوات اتحاديه وهذا القرار
المهم الذي يسحب كل
الذرائع التي تتدرع بها الاخر بان الحدود
ما ممسوكه من قوات الرسميه الامر الذي
يسمح بدخول المتسللين ملف التسليح هل
لديكم يعني هل هناك خطوط حمراء ان لا
يتعامل العراق مع دوله ما لعمليه التسليح
وماذا يحتاج العراق من تسليه ما هو النقص
اللي ممكن يتم استكماله لبناء قوات عراقيه
قادره للدفاع عن السياده العراقيه
والاراضي العراقيه
بالتاكيد هناك رؤيه وخطه لا يمكن في لقاء
تلفزيون نقول ونكشف
التسليح لكن بشكل عام نحن نميل الى التنوع
بالتسليح من كل دول العالم
بس نقص وانا حسب معلوماتي وفي موضوع
الدفاع الجوي اكثر شيء لدى العراق
كلها معالجه ان شاء الله في موازنه 2023
اقليم كردستان دوله الرئيس هل الخلافه بين
الاتحاد والديمقراطي يؤثر على الحوار
لوجود رؤيه مختلفه بخصوص حصه الاقليم
بخصوص التعامل في موضوع النفط والغاز هل
تعاني من هذا الملف وهل هناك حلول ستكون
لانهاء كل الخلافات والتصوير الخلافات ما
بين بغداد خاصه بان صديقك السيد جرفان
بارزاني كان قد قال انه شنو بقاءنا في
ائتلاف الدوله اذا لم يكن هناك تنفيذ لما
تم التوقيع عليه
الاتفاق السياسي لائتلاف اداره الدوله ضمن
الالتزامات تنفيذيه وتشريعيه
الحكومه حريصه على تنفيذ هذه الالتزامات
وفق الدستور والقانون وبالفعل شكلت لجنه
وزاريه تتابع هذه الالتزامات ونعمل على
تنفيذها بشكل واضح وهناك مواقف رسميه بهذه
الالتزامات
يجب ان تحل هذه المشاكل
وننطلق الى افق ارحب واوسع في مساله
تقويه النظام السياسي وبناء الثقه وما
ينعكس على مجمل الخطط الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه التي سوف ينعم بها ابناء شعبنا
سواء كان في اقليم كردستان او الانبار او
البصره
المشاكل العالقه ملفات مرحله في كل حكومه
ترحل الى الحكومه الاخرى ونشهد هذه
التجاربات وضعت بشكل دقيق
وشخصت بدءا من الموازنه وان شاء الله
تقريبا انتهينا من اعدادتها مرورا بتشريع
قانون النفط والغاز الذي سوف ينظم كل
الاجراءات والسياسات المتعلقه ثروه النفط
والغاز وانتهاء بمشاكل ثانويه تتعلق
بالحدود والمنافذ وغيرها هذه كلها قابله
للتنفيذ انا من تبنيت هذه من التزمت بهذه
القضايا وجدتها قابله للتنفيذ انا مو
غريبه على العمليه السياسيه ورافقه
الحكومات كلها هناك فرصه لتنفيذها
بالتاكيد استقرار الوضع السياسي في اقليم
كردستان بين الاخوه الديمقراطي والاتحاد
عامل قوه مهم لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق وانا
حريص على هذا الاتفاق
وحده الاقليم بقرار رسمي والسياسي
لا يوجد عائق لحد الان هناك
تفاؤل في داخل اقليم كردستان من خلال
الاجتماعات ومن خلال الخطوات العمليه التي
تنفذ من قبل الحكومه بشان تنفيذ الاتفاق
ملف الكهرباء على ما يبدو بانه سيكون هو
الصيف العراق ساخن لكن سيكون اكثر سخونه
اذا لم يتم معالجه موضوع الكهرباء كما
تعرف هناك نقص في الامدادات والاطلاقات
الغازيه الى العراق خاصه انه ايضا الشتاء
حصل في تدبب في تجهيز الكهرباء هل
استكملتم عمليه مصادر اخرى للطاقه لطاقه
الكهرباء غير ايران وهل ما زلتم تعانون من
عمليه الدفع الاموال للجانب الايراني هل
توصلتم الى اتفاق مع واشنطن لاعطائكم مثلا
استثناء لدفع هذه الاموال هل ممكن لايران
ان تزيد حصص الغاز في الصيف ام لا سنعاني
من هذا الموضوع
مشاكل القطاع الكهرباء كثيره لكن ممكن
نجملها اولا في
وجود الخطه والرؤيه لتنفيذ مشاريع الصيانه
او التاهيل واكمال بعض مشاريع الانتاج
والنقل والتوزيع وزير الكهرباء قدم رؤيه
وخطه واضحه بتوقيتات زمنيه منذ اليوم
الاول اعطينا اهتمام لتنفيذ هذه الخطه
انطيناه صلاحيات
وفرنا له تخصيصات ماليه هي الاكثر
وساعدناه في ابرام اتفاقات على مستوى
الشركات الكبرى سيمنس جي
واتفقنا اتفاق مبادئ وتوقيع عقود من
المؤمل ان يتم توقيع عقود مع شركه جنرال
الكتريك قريبا بعد ما وقعنا عقود مع او
مذكره مع
وقريبا ايضا وقع عقود معه هذه الشركات
عالميه مختصه وكل محطاتنا هي من خلال هذه
الشركات هناك عمل مستمر في مجال النقل
والتوزيع المشكله مشكله الكهرباء انه
الوقود الذي يشغل المحطات هو ابن الغاز
المستورد من الجاره ايران وايران تنطيه
رغم حاجتها للغاز لكن من باب دعم
استمرار تدفق الامدادات الكهرباء في داخل
العراق مشكلتنا لحد الان انه
تسليم مستحقات ايران اللي وصلت بحدود 11
مليار يورو موجوده في ارصده المصارف
العراقيه كمستحقات
طبعا هذه العمليه تدري العقوبات الثنائيه
او الاحاديه بين الولايات المتحده يعني
خلفيه
القضايا العالقه بين البلدين العراق لا
يريد ان يكون طرف في هذه المعادله لكن
بنفس الوقت انت تاخذ غاز تعرض عليك دوله
تعطي مستحقات
جزء من اتفاق او حوار واشنطن كان هو في
تنفيذ الاليه اللي كانت سائده في زمن
حكومه السيد عادل عبد المهدي وحكومه السيد
الكاظمي كانت في اليه متبعه ومتفق عليها
صار اتفاق على تفعيلها واطلاق جزء من هذه
الاموال انتقل الى الملف العلاقات
الخارجيه كيف تستطيع ان تمسك العصا من
الوسط ما بين العلاقه ما بين ايران
و واشنطن
ايران الدوله جاره لدينا معها من
المشتركات الدينيه الاجتماعيه الثقافيه
الواضحه
و يهمنا ان تكون علاقتنا طيبه معها
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه شريك
استراتيجي للعراق
لدينا التعاون في مجال مكافحه الارهاب
لدينا اتفاقيه اطار استراتيجي
وهناك مصالح متبادله
انا حديثي مع الطرفين بدون ان اختفي وراء
الكلمات او الشعارات واضح وهذا الوضوح
اوصلنا الى تفاهمات عميقه مع الطرفين الى
ماهيه مصالح
مصلحه العراق ومصالح هذه الدول
وفق قاعده المعروفه من مصالح المشتركه
وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لا نريد
للعراق ان يكون
ساحه صراع وانما نقطه التقاء
للدول لا نريد ان نكون جزء من ازمه او
محور في المنطقه او العالم
العراق
رؤيته وخصوصا الحكومه هذه الحاليه هي تبنت
العلاقات المتوازنه ونحن ماضون بهذا
الاتجاه ملف تواجد القوات الامريكيه او
قوات التحالف كنت قد قلت في تصريح سابق
بادى العراق ما زال بحاجه الى هذا الوجود
تقصد وجود المستشاري لدعم القوات العراقيه
لكن يعني هل هناك تفاهم لتوفير الحمايه
خاصه بالاتصال مع الرئيس بايدن مع دولتكم
ايضا تحدث عن ظروف توفير حمايه للمستشارين
العاملين في العراق لانه خلال ايام القريه
الماضيه كان هناك استهداف لبعض الارتال
اللوجستيه التابعه لهذه القوات
لا توجد قواعد عسكريه اجنبيه على الاراضي
العراقيه
الاجهزه الامنيه العراقيه
اكتسبت خبره نستطيع القول بكل ثقه هي
الاقدر والاكثر كفاءه بين الاجهزه الامنيه
في المنطقه وحتى في بعض الاجهزه
وصلت للترتيب الثالث الرابع وحتى في
فعاليات الثانيه على مستوى العالم من حيث
المقدره والمهاره في اداء واجبات يعني ما
عندنا مشكله في قوات قتاليه اليوم احنا ما
عندنا داعش يمسك ارض ابدا داعش الان
مطارده في الجحور في الكهوف في الصحاره مو
بالمدن ما يتجرا يتواجد في منطقه سكنيه
ابدا هذا يدفعنا الى انه القول والتمسك
بموقفنا اللي معلن في اكثر من مناسبه انه
لا نحتاج قوات قتاليه من اي جهه وانما
نحتاج الى تعاون امني استخباراتي معلوماتي
تدريب تمكين تعاون الارهاب مو فقط في
المنطقه اليوم الارهاب واحد من جوانبه اكو
تمويل من دول العالم هذا التمويل ياتي من
دول العالمي للارهاب سواء كانت العراق او
في سوريا
بدون ان تكون لديك منصه للتعاون مع
المجتمع الدولي بالتاكيد سوف تكون جهودك
منقوصه لمكافحه الارهاب الحوار بهذا
الاتجاه القضيه الاخرى نحن لا نسمح
بالاعتداء على البحثات الدبلوماسيه او
المستشارين اللي موجودين مثل ما نسمع انه
الارض العراقيه تكون منطلق للاعتداء على
دول هذه هي المعادله معادله معادله
الاستقرار الامني اللي الحكومه حريصه على
تنفيدها
هذا الفهم
لطبيعه الوجود التحالف الدولي كان واحد من
المواقف الواضحه في احاديثنا والتي سوف
تترجم الى تفاهمات رسميه قريبا ان شاء
الله ملف حصر السلاح بيد الدوله من ضمن
البنود اللي موجوده في البرنامج الحكومي
هل الحكومه قادره على ضبط هذا السلاح هو
سلاح مختلف ما بين عشائر الى مهربين
مخدرات الى فصائل المسلحه العراق تدين
القدره على ضبط هذا السلاح حسب هذا السلاح
في هذه الدوله بدون شك الاجهزه الامنيه
الرسميه قادره على بسط الامن هو سلطه
انفاذ القانون في كل ارجاء العراق وحصر
السلاح ضمن
نطاق ومسؤوليه الاجهزه الامنيه الرسميه
وهذا ما نعمل عليه في كل مكان نحن لدينا
خطط لكنها تاتي وتنفذ بشكل مراحل خطط على
مستوى عاده انتشار الاجهزه الامنيه لا
يمكن ان يبقى الجيش في المدن بدانا بتسليم
محافظات المرحله الاولى والمرحله الثانيه
ايضا سوف تشمل محافظات يجب ان يكون الجيش
دوره واضح في حمايه الحدود والمعسكرات
خارج المدن
ووزاره الداخليه تاخذ على عاتقها القيام
ببهام المسؤوليه
هذه الحوارات مع الوضع الدولي هي جزء من
سحب السلاح من اطراف ترى ان وجود اجانب او
قواعد هذا عملي يهدد الامن وكل واحد الى
عقيده والى موقف بكره من يكون عندك اتفاق
مع الوضع الدولي للشكل العلاقه وانه ماكو
قواعد
قتاليه
وطائرات وجيوش
بالتاكيد اي طرف من الذين يحمل السلاح
تكون مبرراته منتهيه امام هذا المنطق
وامام هذا الشكل الجديد من العلاقه اذا
قرار الحرب والسلم هو بيد الدوله العراقيه
بالتاكيد الدوله العراقيه ومؤسساتها
الرسبيه لا يمكن ان يصادر هذا الدور ولا
يمكن للحكومه ان تسمح لاي جهه بسجل العراق
في حروب او صراعات خلاف المصلحه الوطنيه
العلاقه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه دوله
الرئيس كيف توجد شكل هذه العلاقه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دوله محوريه
وشريك استراتيجي للعراق ما بيننا من
الثقل والوجود على المستوى العربي
والاسلامي وكذلك ما لدينا من ثروات وموارد
كلها مزايا ممكن ان تؤسس للعراق والسعوديه
ان يكون يكون
محور
ومرتكز لنظام اقليمي مستقر يكون واحد من
اهم
الدعامات الاستقرار الاقتصادي والسياسي
والامني في المنطقه والعالم
هذه رؤيتنا لعلاقتنا مع الاشقاء في
السعوديه كان لي لقاء مع سمو ولي العهد في
الرياض على هامش القمه العربيه الصينيه
وتحدثنا بوضوح واتفقنا على جدول اعمال
لثلاثه سنوات يبدا بزيارات واجتماعات
وتفعيل الشراكات
وبالفعل بدات الزيارات تستقبلنا السيد
وزير الخارجيه السعودي وكذلك ننتظر وزير
التجاره رئيس المجلس التنسيقي ومؤخرا
زارا وزير الداخليه العراقي الرياض وتم
التوقيع على مذكره للتفاهم والتعاون
الامني هي الاولى منذ عام 1983 هذا واحده
من اهم اشكال التعاون والعلاقه المستقبليه
بين البلدين العلاقه مع المحيط العربي
العراق اليوم ومن ضمن ائتلاف او تحالف مصر
العراق
والاردن هل من الممكن ان تكون هناك دول
اخرى في في هذا التحالف هل مؤتمر بغداد
ثلاثه سيعقد في بغداد ام سيكون في دوله
اخرى وهل من الممكن ان يتم طرح قضايا يعني
محوريه للمنطقه العربيه وهل الانفتاح
الدول العربيه يزعج البعض دوله الرئيس
الحكومه تتبنى
الاحتفاظ
بالدور الرياضي للعراق في المنطقه
وعلاقاته بالتحديد مع الاشقاء وهذا الدور
الطبيعي للعراق نحن لا
نقوم بدور خارج وضعنا الطبيعي العراق كان
ولا يزال وسيبقى بهذا الدور الرياضي
والذي يتبنى علاقات
وشراكه مع اشقائه وتفاهم في مختلف القضايا
مصالحنا كدول عربيه تقتضي هذا التقارب
والتفاهم والتباني على مشاريع
وشراكات اقتصاديه احنا تبلينا المصطلح
الدبلوماسيه المنتجه
هذا التكامل الذي يجب ان يكون بين الدول
العربيه يجب ان يكون واقع عملي وليس
شعاراتي هناك عناصر قوه لدى كل دوله في
حال التكامل بين هذه الدول سوف تضيف لنا
جميعا كدول العربيه المزيد من القوه
والاستقرار خصوصا نحن في عالم متحرك
ومتغير في كل الاتجاهات
المؤتمر بغداد ثلاثه سوف يعقد في بغداد
ووفق رؤيه الحكومه الجديده
هذه الرؤيه القائمه على ان بغداد
لم تعد جزء من مشكله امنيه اوسيه او
سياسيه وانما بغداد اليوم هي مفتاح للحل
في المنطقه
ورؤيتنا لعنوان وموضوع بغداد ثلاثه في
رؤيه اقتصاديه العراق قادر ان يجمع دول
المنطقه والعالم
بمشاريع وشراكات اقتصاديه وهذا ما نعمل
عليه كانت هناك زياره مؤخره كما اشرت في
وزير خارج السعوديه وايضا الزياره لوزير
الخارجي الايراني هل
مازلتم تبحثون ان يكون هناك اجتماع جديد
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وطهران على
الاراضي العراقيه وهل
بالمباحثات ستعود من جديد مره ثانيه عملنا
على هذا الامر منذ مبااشره الحكومه ووجدنا
تجاوب ورغبه من الطرفين في استمرار العراق
بلعب هذا الدور
مصلحتنا نلعب هذا الدور ونساهم فيه تقريب
وجهات النظر هذا من شانه ان ينعكس على
المنطقه بالمزيد من الامن والاستقرار نعم
الدوله الرئيس ايضا هناك موضوع اخر وهو
موضوع ايران والولايات المتحده كانت لديكم
زياره الى باريس وايضا كانت هناك اتصالات
مع الجانب الامريكي هل العراق هو ناقل
رسائل ما بين الطرفين ام لا هو ايضا فاعل
في موضوع ان تكون هناك بعض
الاجتماعات او بعض الامور التي يتدخل
العراق فيها يعني ان يكون هناك تخفيف
للازمه ما بين طهران وواشنطن الرؤيه في ان
يكون العراق له دور رياضي ومثل ما ذكرت
هذا هو الدور الطبيعي
بالتاكيد لا تنسجم ان يكون العراق ناقل
للرسائل وانما هو من يبادر وهو من يقترح
ويجد الحلول وفق هذا المنطق حركتنا
زياراتنا
تذهب بهذا الاتجاه ونساهم في وجهات النظر
في كثير من القضايا في المنطقه والعالم
دوله الرئيس عود سريعا الى موضوع
الملف الداخلي المدن المدمره التي كانت
بها داعش والان اصبحت المحرره خلال لقائكم
مع الامين العام المتحده تم الحديث عن
ضروره عوده النازحين واعمار المناطق
المقرره هل لديكم رؤيه حول ذلك بشكل عام
الخدمات والتنميه هي من المحاور
والاولويات ذات
الاهتمام كبير من الحكومه عوده النازحين
وانهاء هذا الملف احد اهم الالتزامات سواء
كان النازحين في الداخل العراقي او
النازحين في الخارج هناك معسكرات ومخيمات
خارج العراق تبنت الحكومه اعاده هذه
العوائل بعد اجراء التدقيق الامني والعمل
على اعاده اندماجهم بالمجتمع وتهيئه
متطلبات هذه العوده سواء كان من اعاده
وتاهيل ب وتوفير مصادر رزقهم ووضعهم
المعيشي ايضا نحن نعمل من خلال الصناديق
والبرامج والخطط سواء كان على مستوى
الوزارات والمحافظات في اكمال البناء
التحتيه في هذه المحافظات للمستشفيات
ومدارس
وخدمات بلديه هذا عمل متواصل واتابعه بشكل
مفصل مع المحافظين سواء كان خلال
الاجتماعات الهيئه التنسيقيه او من خلال
زياراتي الميدانيه ملف الاسكان في العراق
ايضا اصبح ملف معقد اليوم العاصمه
العراقيه مقتظه جدا هل لديكم رؤيه حول
موضوع التطوير الاسكاني وتوزيع الاراضي
دوله الرئيس طبعا ازمه السكن خضعت لكثير
من التجارب من توزيع قطع اراضيه
وبناء مجمعات سكنيه من خلال المستثمرين
لكنها لم تسهم في حل الازمه اقول لذلك
احنا درسنا كل هذه التجارب والافكار وتم
صياغه مشروع خاص بهذه الحكومه
للتغلب على هذه الازمه
طيله الاشهر الثلاثه وهذا الشهر الرابع
ونحن نعكف على دراسه هذا المشروع وتهيئه
من كل المتطلبات حتى يكون مشروع قابل
للتطبيق وليس وعود انا حريص على تنفيذ
التزاماتي امام الشعب
وانتبه جدا لهذه القضيه لانه هي اساس
فقدان الثقه بين الشعب والطبقه السياسيه
في حل مشاكل مزمنه للمواطنين مشكله السكن
ان شاء الله وفق ما مخطط لها سوف تكون
واقع عملي وبحلول يلمسها المواطن في
القريب العاجل رؤيتك لي موازنه العراق
الاتحاديه لعام 23
تاخرنا بالموازنه نوعا ما اللي عده اسباب
واحد من اسباب التاخير وكيف ان اربط
الموازنه مع البرنامج الحكومي في كل
الحكومات السابقه الحكومه تنطي برنامجها
الحكومه في البرلمان وتاخذ الثقه وتنتهي
العمليه والظل مجرد شعارات وخطوط عامه هذه
الحكومه لا نريد البرنامج وفق اولويات
الاربعه موجود في الموازنه لان انت شلون
تنفذ البرنامج اذا ما يتم ادخاله في
مشاريع وبرامج وخطط وسياسات في موازنتك
اللي هي فيها الاموال والانفاق ومشاكل هذا
التاخير هو لاجل مواءمه البرنامج مع
الموازنه وهذا ما حصل لله الحمد الذي
سؤالين اخرين دوله الرئيس ملف الدياله و
هل نحن امام عوده اصطفاف طائفي وهل هذا
مسموح ابدا غير مسموح هذا ما يعمل عليه
داعش ونحن
نتابع هذا الامر بدقه وتم اجهاض كل هذه
المحاولات وتعقب المجرمين الذين حاولوا
احداث هذه الفتنه كانت هناك ضربات موجعه
للارهابيين في هذه المناطق وسوف تستمر
وايضا ضربات للقتله والمجرمين الذين
استباحوا الدماء العراقيه هناك اسماء كان
المواطن في ديالى ما يعتقد انه الاجهزه
الامنيه سوف تقوم باعتقالهم تم اعتقالهم
وهم الان خلف القطبان نحن متمسكون
بالتزامنا الشرعي والوطني والاخلاقي بعدم
السماح بالسباحه الدم العراقي في اي مكان
ولا عوده للطائفيه ابدا
الشعب تجاوز هذه المحنه ولله الحمد ملف
التوازن الوطني يعني اليوم كان هناك بيان
للسياده ينتقد اداء وزيره في عمليه اقصاء
والتهيش هل تضع في نصف عينك موضوع يكون
هناك توازن وطني في عمل التغيير وايضا
موضوع الملف الامني انه البعض يقول بان
السيد محمد الشاه السوداني ذهب لرئاسه
جهاز المخابرات وذهب لاعطاء الامن الوطني
رئاسه احد الوزراء لحين استكمالا تكون
لديه رؤيه صحيحه
يعني تمسك بعض القيادات الامنيه هذه
المناصب الحساسه اولا بالنسبه للتوازن اكو
فرق بين التوازن وجود المكونات في كل
المؤسسات الدوله وبين انه الجهات السياسيه
تتحكم بتسميه
المسؤولين في الوزارات
احنا مع التوازن اني اجيبه سني بس مو انت
تفرض علي احسنت واجيبك كردي بس مو انت
تفرض علي واجيب الشيعه بس منت تفرض علي
ولا مسموح لك
انه تعترض على قرار وزير او وزيره الوزير
او الوزير عندما تتخذ قرار في اعفاء مسؤول
وفق مبررات
الوزير ورئيس الوزراء لا يستاذن ولا يحتاج
ان يستمع للاخر في اتخاذ قرار باتجاه
اقاله
مساله التوازن انا حريص على تواجد كل
مكونات الشعب العراقي لكن وفق قاعده
الكفاءه والنزاهه والتخصص احنا نريد نبني
الدوله بناء صحيح مو نبنيها انه هذا شيعي
يكون يصير بهذا الموقع وهذا يكون بهذا
الموقع وهذا كردي يكون بهذا الموقع ابدا
وين مبدا المواطنه طيب احنا شو نقول للشعب
اللي رفض المحاصصه احنا اتمنينا نبذ
المحاصصه في مشاريعنا في برامجنا
الانتخابيه ليش نريد نرجع لها هذا جانب
جانب الاخر اللي يتعلق بالاجهزه الامنيه
الاجهزه الامنيه انا حريص على
اصلاح المؤسسه الامنيه من 2003 واحنا في
نفس النمط
يعني اكو سياقات وجدتها بشهاده الضباط
موجوده من سنه 2007 واحنا اليوم تكلم عن
هذا التشابك بين الاجهزه الامنيه لذلك
شكلت لجنه للاصلاح المؤسسات الامنيه
براستي
واضويه مختصين وانا حريص على ان تبقى هذه
الاجهزه الامنيه في اطارها المهني بعيده
كل البعد عن اي استثمار سياسي او حزبي
لانه المقتل في ان تكون هذه الاجهزه
الامنيه مسيسه يجب ان يكونوا للوطن وتنفذ
واجباتها مهامها بما يخدم كل ابناء الشعب
الانتخابات البرلمانيه المبكره هل هو قرار
بيدي كتل السياسيه اذا كانت مبكره
بالتاكيد والقدستور يجب ان يكون هناك حل
لمجلس النواب واذا ارتات القوه السياسيه
ان تحل مجلس النواب فالحكومه جاهزه لتامين
متطلبات اقامه انتخابات السيد محمد اشياء
السوداني رئيس الوزراء العراقي شكرا على
هذا الحوار ولساعه صدرك وايضا اشكر موصول
لمساعد الكرام والى مقابله اخرى